in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatments alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape joining me in
the studio today is neurologist
professor Martine Holcomb he's director
of the berlin-brandenburg
epilepsy Center hello and welcome to the
show hello welcome
how should you react if you witness
someone with a seizure so I think first
of all all witnesses can be can keep
calm on the patient so and they should
protect the patient from any injuries
and you have to differentiate what kind
of epileptic seizure this is and if it's
a gourmets seizure what we know what the
patient does not have any control over
his body you just should help him and
maybe gently hold the head that there
are no injuries afterwards and how can
you differentiate it's a lay man so to
say so the the the the Grand Palais is
where you lose your consciousness yes
and you are just falling on the floor
and then you have a tonic movement and
you have a stretching of X dimitris and
then you have convulsions and the
smaller seizures what we say they
usually are arising in the temporal
lobes and the patient would stay to sit
in a seat and his absence are not react
to any comments or any questions and may
have some oral automatisms for example
what you've seen the movie as well and
are there any common mistakes usually
people do when they try to help an
epileptic patient yeah it's very common
that people think they have to put
something in the mouths of patients who
have a gamma seizure and I think they
want to protect them that they bite on
their tongue and it happens sometimes
but it's not the tongue the muscle
itself so there's really no injury
afterwards and you really can harm the
patient when you put something in the
mouth because you can break out the
teeth of the patient and the helper
himself can hurt him because it's very
strong motor activity and you can hurt
the finger of the person once later so
if we take a finger inside for example I
can keep away from all of this don't put
anything of the most and do you always
have to call an ambulance and call a
doctor after seizure yeah it depends so
when a patient has a chronic epilepsy
and the family for example our friends
know
what an epileptic seizure is typical for
this patient and there's next typical
seizure we don't recommend to call an
ambulance but if it's a first seizure
for example or if you just witness
something on the street and you don't
know the person then of course you have
to call an ambulance it could be the
first seizure and it could be an alarm
signal of something really severe injury
in the brain mm okay and and how
dangerous are seizures for themselves
I'm not speaking about brain tumors
causing em seizures but the seizure can
can you lose some brain cells due to the
seizure so the dangerous thing is that
you can hurt yourself because you don't
have control during the seizure and that
the scissors are unpredictable you know
I have no idea when it occurs but inside
the brain we have a lot of hints that
even when you have five seizures a month
there is a higher quite a seizure
frequency you really don't have a loss
on death of newer of neurons and this is
a very important information for the
patients but there are some problems if
you got a seizure say while swimming
for instance yeah for examine risk of
dying during epileptic seizure because
you can imagine when you're swimming on
a lake but also if you're in your
bathtub if it's only water of a half a
meter you can drown and then you have a
high risk of dying that is 20 times
higher than in people without epilepsy
so that's really dangerous and then what
about the genetic risks we got a view
question from South America Maria Lopez
wants to know her mother suffers from
epilepsy has Maria and her kids some
increased risk of developing epilepsy
yeah it depends on what kind of epilepsy
you have and we have these genetic
epilepsies that are maybe 15 to 20
percent of all epilepsies but even in
the genetic epilepsy is the risk that
your offsprings have epilepsy is maybe
six to eight percent so it's highly
unlikely
and you shouldn't refrain from getting
children only because you have epilepsy
because the holcomb can surgery treat
epilepsy effectively yes so when you
look at the subgroup of patients who
have partial epilepsy that means they
have seizures that arise from one point
from one focus on the brain and they
don't can and they can't be treated with
antibiotics drugs then they should be
assessed for epilepsy surgery and when
you look at the right from persons then
they have for seventy to eighty percent
chance of completely getting seizure
free so it's highly effective in the sub
patience so they see the serie free for
the rest of their life yes yes okay but
many patients are candidates for
operation and surgery so they need to
take medications and how does a Pepsi
medication work yeah so the mainstay of
treatment of course is an elliptic drug
treatment and seventy to eighty percent
of patients are seizure free with these
drugs and they work at the end that they
decrease the excitability of the brain
and there are different mechanisms and
that stops the occurrence of seizures
but also the propagation of seizures so
maybe a seizure of course but it's not a
coma a seizure but a smaller seizure as
we have seen the movie before but if I
decrease brain activity with a pill it
doesn't mean that there are serious side
effects it can be so they do not only
act against epilepsy they also act on
alertness for example or wakefulness so
some patients complain that a little bit
sleepy but now in the last 15-20 years
we have a couple of very new drugs and
they're as efficient as the older ones
but they have a lot of less side effects
and are well tolerated
so the majority of patients is free of
seizures takes one drug and has no that
does not have any side effects but the
drugs don't cure epilepsy so you have to
stay on them yes that's true they don't
cure epilepsy they just prevent the
occurrence of the next epileptic seizure
so it's a kind of secondary prophylaxis
and the question in what in which
patients you can stop the drugs is a
very individual one and a lot of factors
regarding ecology and the syndrome and
the expectations of the patient when you
decide to stop a drug or not and that
can there must be individualized this
decision and they say anything you can
do aside from taking pills we got a view
a question from India deviating Bulli
wants to know is a special diet for
epileptic patients to get rid of
seizures that's a very old concept I
think it's 80 years old no it's called a
ketogenic diet and that means that you
have a very high fraction of fatty acids
in your diet and then the metabolism is
changed in the body the body produces
so-called ketone bodies and they enter
the brain and they have anti epileptic
activity but this is no alternative to
drugs it's an endorsement of epileptic
drugs so it's an add-on treatment but it
works in some patients but you have to
be very strict on this diet and it's not
so easy and what about other points of
life can epileptic patients lead a
normal life say with
alcohol intake so the majority of people
can have a very normal life and we say
you don't have to refrain from taking
alcohol when you drink a lot and you are
drunk then the next morning the alcohol
goes out of the body and that's a period
of very high brain excitability I think
everybody knows who without epilepsy
gets drunk but that's high risky but
they're not so normal social equal in
tech it's no problem and we recommend
you to drink if people want to drink if
they don't want they don't have to and
what about other parts of normal life
like like being a surgeon for instance
of being a pilot and are those jobs an
alternative for epileptic patients or
there are some specific rules because
you don't have to harm other people so
what you're doing to yourself it's your
own decision but you can't harm other
people that's why they are driving
restrictions patients epilepsy are not
allowed to drive a car unless they are
seizure free for one year and this also
applies for different jobs for example
or occupations such as physician but
that's again it's an individual decision
but usually they have to be one year
seizure free and then they can do their
jobs and operate fine it's a little bit
different so if you electric you have to
speak to a neurologist to see if you can
become a surgeon professor outcome
thanks so much for being with us in the
studio today thank you
you